somewhere down the line in your chest
career the question does comes to your
mind
what is the most aggressive yet
trickiest reply to Evo
the answer is very obvious
elephant campet
simple
easy to play free piece play and yet it
has a Venom to even confuse title
players
so join with me and learn
not only some of the very high profile
tricks and traps exist in this line but
time to time I'm also going to show you
my own suggestion which will complete
the mini rap router of this campage
[Music]
well as you can see I have choose the
leeches interface and the reason is very
obvious just keep your one eye on the
database which is just situated below me
which will give you a very good idea how
many people exactly fall for the
specific trick
after E4 E5 Knight to F3
black plays the trademark elephant
Gambit move D5
and as you can see we already limit the
white option
and by far as I have highlighted over
here these are the three popular choices
now since this is an introduction
to encourage you let me show you some of
the quick bullet trap which many good
players fallen into
and the first one you might get
surprised as if you scroll down this
database and if you look at this move
Bishop to C4
000 yep so 18 000 people fall for Bishop
C4
and after simple d-capture C4
you will probably get the fastest
victory in your entire chess carrier if
your opponent realized that he lost the
piece and resigned the game
don't laugh this can happen
honor the frequent move which many new
learner of Royal Pass
place and if you scroll down again the
database
we have Bishop to B5 played in roughly
5000 games
which is again a good mistake because
after C6 attacking the bishop
suddenly white realize oops I have a
problem the E4 Pawn is hanging
so Bishop to D3 2000 games played
fake blunder guys
D capture C4 Bishop capture C4 and yogis
is equally good as mine
yup fi and the pieces strap there
because if he continue with Bishop to D3
then after E4 obviously black wins the
piece
probably the most trickiest reply here
is Knight captures E5
and White's big idea is if you foolishly
take this bishop then Queen to H5 is a
deadly reply
of course we are not in a hurry and the
move which I am going to recommend here
is very simple
Queen to F6
attacking two pieces and now no matter
however white plays
he is going to be pieced down just
within the opening stage
for example D4 and now F capture Z4
once again gives black a completely
winning age just within the opening
stage
so that's it guys I hope with this mini
introduction I have encouraged you to
take this Gambit in Europe Ruta stay
tuned as we are going to see some of the
most high profile tricks and traps in
this line
which will literally blow your mind
thank you for watching this and don't
forget to like subscribe and comment